3000 bis 4000 menschen montagsdemo in
leipzig und mitten unter ihnen mitten in
deutschland extremisten von links und
rechts sie demonstrieren sie kann deren
wir sind das volk unter ihnen auch die
freien sachsen einer als rechtsextrem
eingestufte organisation oder auch die
linke und anhänger der linksextremen sie
demonstrieren gegen die energiepolitik
und die gestiegenen kosten und das alles
obwohl nur wenige stunden zuvor das neue
dritte 65 milliarden euro entlastungs
paket beschlossen wurde sieben
angemeldete demos 2500 linke und mehr
als 1000 rechte auf dem augustusplatz in
leipzig freie sachsen querdenker leipzig
nimmt platz und die kommunistische rote
wände anti vfb-anhänger sie alle machen
aus ihrer gesinnung kein hill sie
schwenken weiß rote fahnen des deutschen
reichs jubeln in chemnitzer
rechtsradikalen martin kohlmann und
unter anderem auch ex half dem mann
andre poggenburg ist die frage ob es da
wirklich allen um die energiepolitik
gehen
rechtsextreme linke und linksextreme auf
einem platz mitten in deutschland doch
es sind nicht nur radikale die auf die
straße gehen neben den links- und
rechtsextremen in leipzig sind doch
einfach nur besorgte bürger menschen die
angst haben angst vor den gestiegenen
strom- und gaskosten und mit einigen von
ihnen haben wir gesprochen
wir demonstrieren dafür dass die
versorgung in deutschland gesichert wird
und dass diese versorgung nicht
zugunsten der energiekonzerne erfolg
sondern zugunsten der kleinen leute als
event 800 euro hier gas bezahlen muss
oder
das geht nicht das hat keiner ich bin
für volksentscheide in wichtigen fragen
jetzt das ist mein anliegen war ich
prinzipiell gegen die politik bin
momentan betrieben wird die
konzeptionslose ist und für mich nicht
nachvollziehbar das ist mir egal was
rechte leute denken oder sagen ich stehe
dafür dass es sozial nicht schlechter
wird in deutschland und hilft weiter
wenn man ein konzept hat wie die
wirtschaft stabilisiert war wie wir
irgendwie auch als deutschland wieder
weiter existieren können denn das was
momentan gemacht wird ist eigentlich nur
ein tropfen auf heiße steine hilft ihm
und wir sind jetzt verbunden mit dem
politikwissenschaftler werner patzelt
der sich mit extremistischen bewegungen
in aus deutschland auskennt herr patzelt
guten morgen wir haben sie die gestrigen
demonstrationen in leipzig wahrgenommen
es war nicht der auftakt zu jedem heißen
herbst vor dem viele politiker gewandt
haben es zeigte sich dass zwar die
politik der bundesregierung auf große
skepsis stößt das es aber nicht zu jedem
grandiosen auftritt von links und
rechtsradikalen gekommen ist denn viele
befürchtet hatten die aufgabe die sich
nach dieser demonstration stellt ist
dass die politik plausible politik
betreibt die die leute auch innerlich
überzeugt
und dass die opposition die vernünftigen
gemischt linksradikal die nichts retten
die nicht rechtsradikal und um
demonstranten sichtbar vertritt und dann
ist das ganze gemäß unseren ordnung im
ablaufen was halten sie davon dass die
freien sachsen den eindruck erwecken zu
versuchen dass es eine gemeinsame
veranstaltung mit den linken gewesen
sein
ja die rechte ist isoliert und wenn die
rechte bemerkt dass sie im grunde die
gleichen ziele vertreten die linke hat
sie natürlich hat interesse daran diese
ausgrenzung zu durchbrechen indem sie
die rechte klarmacht dass er sie auch
nichts anderes will als der linke und
dass es doch nicht falsch sein könnte
was man als rechter sagt wenn die linken
genau das gleiche sagen das ist das
taktische oder sogar strategische
anliegen hinter dem auftreten der
rechten hätten die linken sich
deutlicher im vorfeld distanzieren
müssen
erstens kann man sich kaum deutlicher
distanzieren als der linken das getan
haben bis sie zur aussage von gregor
gysi aus dem schlussredner dass man mit
dem wie er sich ausdrückte rechten
gesorgt selbst nichts zu tun hatte und
zum anderen muss ich schon sagen wenn
man das gleiche politische ziel hat kann
man auch mal das gleiche politische ziel
unterstreichen stadt das ritual weiter
zu betreiben dass man selbst bei
gleichen zielen mit anderen nichts zu
tun haben will herr patzelt was sagt das
jetzt über die stimmung im land aus im
letzten jahr hatten wir viele corona
demonstrationen menschen sind auf die
straße gegangen um gegen diese maßnahmen
zu demonstrieren jetzt eben wieder
demonstrationen in leipzig zu diesem
thema
man muss sehen dass das
demonstrationsgeschehen dass deutschland
polarisiert schon 2014 begonnen hat im
frühjahr mit der in montags mahnwachen
dann mit den tg der demonstrationen
montagabend in dresden um seitdem ist es
so dass ich in diesem straßenprotest ob
nun bei giga oder corona oder jetzt
einfach zeigt dass ein nennenswerter
teil der bevölkerung den eindruck hat
dass die politische klasse das land in
eine falsche richtung und in probleme
hinein steuert sei es ohne zu wissen was
sie die politiker schafft tut sei es
ohne wissen zu wollen wirst dann die
begleit effekte ihre politik wären es
gibt ein dumpfes unbehagen an der
politik ob berechtigt oder nicht muss
man im einzelnen diskutieren und dieses
unbehagen an der politik diese haltung
der inneren kündigung gegenüber unserer
politiker schafft sie äußert sich in
diesen demonstrationen was glauben sie
wo er net/as wird dieser graben immer
und immer größer
das hängt davon ab wie mit diesem
verbreiteten unwohlsein mit unserer
politik umgegangen wird wenn die politik
nichts anderes zu sagen wir haben recht
alles was wir tun ist alternativlos und
wer das nicht einsieht der iss um das
lied von der kommunistischen partei zu
zitieren der ist dumm oder schlechten
wert in wahrheit hat das immer recht und
die weit ist bei der politik wenn die
politik sich weiterhin so verhält dann
kann dieses demonstrationsgeschehen an
wucht gewinnen wenn politik sich daran
macht darauf zu hören was die leute
umtreibt und dafür problem lösungen
anzubieten oder dort wo die leute
eingebildete probleme benennen zu sagen
freunde aus den gründern a bis b und c
und d 10 euro sei rundum gegründet wenn
also ein vernünftiges gespräch über die
den gegenstand der demonstration und
abgebenden themen versucht wird dann
schaut alle schon ganz anders aus und
rein hängt vieles davon ab wie sich die
lage im winter wirklich entwickelt
müssen wirklich leute frieren gegen der
energiepreise wirklich ins endlose oder
lässt sich etwa doch das verlängern oft
seien sonderproben kraftwerke gegen die
jetzige entscheidung zu doch etwas tun
und drittens und nicht zuletzt hängt
alles ab davon wie die massenmedien
berichten wenn der tenor der
berichterstattung der ist das besorgte
bürger legitime probleme haben welche
die politik nicht aufgreift wird das
schicksal der demonstrationen ein
anderes sein als wenn der medien teno
darin besteht dass jene die immer schon
die feinde unserer ordnung waren sich
jetzt auf der straße unter vorwänden
zusammenfinden also wir können nicht
wissen wie es kommt wir wissen aber was
die entscheidenden stellschrauben sind
die prägen was kommen wird sagt
politikwissenschaftler werner patzelt
herzlichen dank für dieses gespräch
gerne
[Musik]